Alright, so now let's, let's get back to our data set that
we were looking at before. So again, the ideas that we're, we're going to
try to find a way of predicting the value for various points along
the way on this curve. And one thing we could do is find
the best line. But we also talked now about finding the best constant.
Turns out these all belong to a family of functions that we could
fit. Which are functions of this form. Alright. We've got x is our
input and what we're going to do is we're going to take some constant and
add that to some scaled version of x times some scaled version of x squared plus
some scaled version of x cubed, all the way up to some order k. And we've
talked about k equals zero, the constant function.
And k equals one, the line. But there's
also k equals two, parabola. Would it probably
be a good choice at this particular case?
>> Yes.
>> It does seem like it's got, sort of, curvy downy nature, right?
>> Mm hm.
>> It's
going up and it's kind of flattening out and maybe we could
imagine that it starts coming down again? At least, over the course of
these points, it doesn't come down again but at least it sort of
flattened out. So let's take a look at that. Let's take a look
at the. The best parabola to fit this. Alright, so, so here
we go. We've got the, the best line now, the best constant function
which is just the average. We have the best line with some slope
to it. That's the green one. We have now the best parabola and
look at it, it does, it does a nice job,
right? Kind a gets, gets tucked in with all those other
points. so, so what do you think? Is this the
best way of, of capturing this. This particular set of points?
>> Well, if the only thing we care about is minimizing the sum of squared
error, my guess is that the parabola has less squared error.
>> Yeah. It ha, there's more degrees of freedom so at the worst
we could have just fit the parabola as a line. Right.
We can always just set any of these coefficients to, to zero.
So if the best fit to this really was a line. The
best fit to this data point was a line, then the parabola
that we see here wouldn't have any curve to it. So,
yeah. Our arrows going down. Hm, As we have gone from order
zero to order one to order two. So can you think of
any other way getting there in order to getting down even more.
>> How about order
14 million.
>> Interesting, while in this particular case,
given the amount of data that we have,
we can't go past the number of
data points, yeh after that. They're really unconstrained.
>> Okay. Then how about order nine?
>> Order nine is a good idea. But just to
give you an idea here, we're going to step up a little
more. This is order four and look at, look at how
lovely it can actually capture the flow here. That's, very faded.
Order six and in fact the best we can do here is of the, of the,
sorry. The most, the highest order that, that
works is order eight. And, son of a gun,
look what it did. It hit every single
point dead on in the center. Boom. Boom. Boom.
Boom. It used all the degrees of freedom
it had to reduce the error to essentially zero.
>> Excellent.
>> So [LAUGH], one could argue that this is a really
good idea. Though, if you look at what happens around 9000,
there's some craziness. Do you see that?
>> I do.
>> At the Yeah, the To try to get this particular parabola
to hit that particular point, it sent the curve soaring down with an up again.
>> We also did that between 6500 and 8500, it sent [CROSSTALK].
>> Yes good point
>> [UNKNOWN] [CROSSTALK]
>> Right, right, that's right went off the top of the plot. So Yeah,
that's kind of [INAUDIBLE]. But let's just, just to show that we really
are, as we have more degrees of freedom we're fitting the error better.
Let me show you what it looks like, the amount of error for
the best fit for each of these orders of k. Alright and so, so
what you see when we actually plot the, the squared error, this function
that we're trying to minimize. As we go from order zero to order
one, order two, order three, order four, order five, all the way to
eight. By eight, there is no error left because it nailed every single point.
So you know its kind of a good, nut it doesn't feel quite
right like the curves that we're looking there looked a little bit crazy.